this video is brought to you by warby
parker
[Music]
what's up guys michael here and today
we're talking about the only franchise
in the world in which an all-star
athlete shares top billing with a
talking rabbit that's right space jam
the original movie had a lot going for
it visual panache an astoundingly
committed human cast you kick it into
the girl bunny yeah down in the post you
dish it back out to the guy bunny
swinging around the mic over here you go
to the hall and dominate we own defense
and then now kind of uncomfortable to
hear soundtrack i believe
it just sounds gross now anyway it
quickly became a childhood staple for
millions of viewers digging out of space
in their hearts with the release of
space jam a new legacy warner brothers
did its best to crack open those same
hearts and mine them for all their juicy
nostalgia because in today's hollywood
nostalgia not money not stardom not top
tier directing prowess is the most
valuable resource but what are movies
like a new legacy actually doing when
they recycle our precious childhood
memories is it a neat way to revamp the
past or just a cynical cash grab from an
industry low on ideas that's a lot to
unpack so let's talk it through in this
wisecrack edition on space jam why
nostalgia rules hollywood what i'm
trying to say is
we need your help
but before we get into it i want to give
a shout out to this week's sponsor
warby parker warby parker makes boutique
quality eyewear without the boutique
prices they are committed to providing
exceptional vision care both online and
in stores they offer eyeglasses
sunglasses eye exams and contact lenses
and maybe most importantly warby parker
glasses look amazing and are available
in a variety of styles and their glasses
start at only 95 dollars including
prescription lenses and if you're not
feeling like heading to the store you
can order your glasses from the comfort
of your favorite chair with warby
parker's free at home try on program you
can get five frames shipped directly to
your house so you can see what looks
best on your own face you have five days
to decide which ones you like with
absolutely no obligation to buy shipping
is free and they even include a pre-paid
return shipping label i took their quiz
to find my ideal glasses and it only
took me a few minutes and i had my
frames within days in the past i've
ordered glasses online without trying
them on and when they showed up i
realized it didn't quite work for my
face but with warby parker's at home
triumph program i got to take my time
try out five unique frames and even ask
my trusty roommate what she thought
looked best on me so find your own
perfect glasses with warby parker's free
home triumph program and try five pairs
for free by going to warbyparker.com
wisecrack there is no obligation to buy
so it's risk free so head to
warbyparker.com wisecrack today now
back to the show first let's look at the
original 1996 space jam the film
features a disgruntled michael jordan
getting sucked down a golf hole only to
end up playing basketball alongside the
looney tunes in an all or nothing game
against a bunch of aliens and while that
synopsis sounds straight up ridiculous
it turned out to be exactly what movie
audiences were looking for ultimately
netting over 230 million dollars come on
michael it's game time get your hands on
lace up your nikes grab your wheaties
and your gatorade we'll pick up a big
mac on the way to the ballpark but the
film's success went way beyond the
movies dubs it was an absolute
merchandising giant launching a tidal
wave of t-shirts sneakers and video
games that one industry insider
estimates garnered somewhere between
four and six billion dollars and of
course there was also that iconic
soundtrack which went platinum six times
over
[Music]
and launched the film's signature track
sung by an artist who is also a horrific
sex criminal in short if you were the
average kid in the late 90s then space
jam wasn't just what you were watching
it was what you were wearing reading
playing and listening to speaking of
toys you know all those mugs and
t-shirts and lunch boxes with our
pictures on them yeah you will ever see
any money from all that stuff not a
scent
we need it
it's a crying shame we gotta get new
agents we're getting screwed and this
kind of attachment is exactly what space
jam a new legacy was banking on the new
film stars lebron james as he is sucked
into the warner brothers server verse by
a nefarious algorithm named
al g rhythm and written by someone who
like me appears to have a very shaky
understanding of what algorithms
actually do they're
alive
after taking a quick tour of all the
other properties which warner brothers
would very much like to remind you that
it owns king james is forced to save the
day by you guessed it teaming up with
the tunes and dunking on a bunch of
animated bad guys led by his own son in
short it's a very familiar story you
want me a talking cartoon bunny to play
with you an nba superstar in a
high-stakes basketball game
sounds awfully familiar the sequel is
part of a major contemporary trend
studios reanimating a decades-old piece
of ip i.e intellectual property like
they did with star wars creed rambo and
a host of others and that's because the
first thing this kind of nostalgia does
is provide a really reliable payday for
the studios at a time when they
desperately need it of course nostalgia
has always been a sort of secret sauce
for hollywood from singing in the reigns
mid-century look back at silent film to
the way indiana jones and star wars drew
on serials from the 40s right up to the
industry's contemporary enthusiasm for
remakes and reboots there has always
been a wide audience for films that gaze
backwards in fact even the original
space jam was steeped in nostalgia it
arrived at a time when the looney tunes
were looking for a new lease on life
after over half a century of cartoons so
warner brothers borrowed some
credibility from one of the world's most
popular people michael jordan
incidentally jordan was in the middle of
some image repair of his own amidst
rumors of a gambling problem his shock
retirement from the nba and a kind of
surreal stint as a minor league baseball
player even as he returned to the nba
there was real uncertainty as to whether
he could fully restore the beloved air
jordan era so space jam doubly revived
the past telling a story in which those
glory days never ended making looney
tunes and michael jordan relevant again
and letting jordan save the day
just by being really good at basketball
while hollywood has always loved a good
nostalgia film it's become something
like their main game in recent years as
doctoral candidate matthew cooper found
over the course of the 2010s the number
of nostalgia films among the 50 highest
domestic grocers rose steadily from 2 in
2010 to 11 in 2019. so if you feel like
every other movie released today is
either a remake reboot prequel or sequel
congrats you're right but that doesn't
necessarily mean that hollywood has run
out of ideas it's more that the ideas
we're already familiar with tend to be
reliably more bankable and to understand
why we need to understand what nostalgia
is and what makes it so powerful and
we'll leave that to one of tv's most
cynical and drunk protagonists nostalgia
it's delicate
but potent sounds a little like a
basketball court stacked with looney
tunes and a beloved charismatic nba
player now the word nostalgia was
initially coined to describe an apparent
medical affliction suffered by a
homesick swiss soldiers in the 17th
century since then it's gradually
evolved into a term for what mr draper
describes the sweet slightly melancholic
sensation of being transported back to a
place in time where we feel more at home
and this sensation seems to have become
a central part of today's pop culture
with literary scholars svetlana boyam
even describing nostalgia as the
incurable modern condition so why are we
all so obsessed with the past well
largely because the present
kind of sucks pretty much every aspect
of 21st century life has become fraught
with uncertainty and instability from
the economic shifts which have created a
generation of renters and gay workers to
the technological changes which have
transformed our social lives and
communication to a pop culture which
burns through content at an ever
increasing rate oh and also the uh the
modern plague this has created what
polish sociologist sigmund bauman
described as a liquid modern world that
is a world which is changing too rapidly
to keep up with so it's no surprise that
many of us find ourselves grasping
backwards in search of something solid
to hold on to whether it's the antics of
wild e coyote or the star power of lola
bunny it's also worth noting that the
liquid world of the 21st century has
left the film industry in the weeds
streaming services have issued a major
challenge to the central place that
movie theaters once occupied meanwhile
advances in technology have made it
possible for television to tell stories
with the same sort of scope and polish
as hollywood's fair in short modernity
has rapidly marched us towards a place
where the movie business is unsure of
its place in the world as any of us
regular schmucks are and just like us
the studio bigwigs have developed a
tendency to meet this uncertain future
by retreating into the past with
familiar ip and franchise building
movies seem to be the only safe bet
hence why disney has 109 star wars
spin-offs in the oven clifford the big
red dog is about to slobber all over our
screens and greta gerwig is making a
barbie movie and also hence why we have
space jam a new legacy a film which
exists both to cash in on our affection
for the first film and to advertise the
matrix austin powers fury road and all
the other beloved movies which viewers
can find on hbo max after the end
credits roll the possibilities are
endless
you'll be the king of warner brothers
but what are these films really doing
when they serve us up all the warm 90s
feels
arguably
nothing good the key problem with films
like a new legacy is that they offer
only what scholars like emily kitely and
michael pickering refer to as regressive
nostalgia films which in their selective
utilization of idealized images from the
past only attend to backward longing
while ignoring necessary dimensions of
lack and loss basically these are films
which are shot through a rose-tinted
lens and they make no attempt to
question whether things really were so
much better back when michael jordan
ruled the court or while we're so
attached to these specific looney tunes
themed morsels of the past and so a new
legacy seems content to recreate or nod
to moments from the film that it's
echoing
rather than offering any sort of nuanced
commentary about the original instead
these films bank on what has proven to
be a pretty fair expectation the
viewer's childhood attachment will be
enough to keep them engaged this might
be a good strategy when you're just
trying to sell people more of something
they already like but it boxes
filmmakers into making movies that exist
solely to not back at those which came
before and that's basically what a new
legacy amounts to a feature-length
reminder of movies you once enjoyed what
in the matrix hell but there's something
slightly more sinister about all this
and it has to do with the way ip
functions in hollywood as the
entertainment industry increasingly
consolidates under just a few corporate
umbrellas ip has become its product from
disney acquiring star wars to viacom cbs
further building out the world of avatar
the last airbender ip overlaps with
nostalgia because it entails recycling
beloved characters and worlds to
capitalize off of brands rather than
creating challenging works of art and
indeed the entire premise of space jam a
new legacy and most of its gags are
predicated on the fact that warner
brothers owns a ton of ip and thus
effectively a more than decent hunk of
the media we already know and love but
rather than questioning the increased
consolidation of the entertainment world
the film argues that this reality is
objectively good because it allows for
fun cinematic universe crossover moments
as john semley notes in the baffler the
original space jam was also chock full
of references but it evokes properties
outside the warner brothers universe
like patent pulp fiction and doctor who
and even has vaguely subversive moments
that mock warner brothers sprawling
empire what's more the looney tunes
explicitly seem to fear an ip driven
recycling obsessed world after all if
they lose the big game they'll be
consigned to perform at a theme park
replaying their greatest hits
space jam a new legacy in contrast stays
firmly within the warner brothers
universe it's literally set inside a
digital manifestation of this world and
it's nothing if not a celebration of
this reality it expects us to be happy
that these guys own everything we love
assembly writes space jam foretells a
future if not a present that wants us to
recognize the realities of intellectual
property it asks us not to forget the
condition of our own subservience to
mega corporations but to cheer it in
this way it's arguably even less
subversive than its original
manipulating our nostalgia to make us
more comfortable with the vaguely
uncomfortable realities of an
entertainment world driven by
consolidation and branding in stark
contrast other long-running franchises
have perfectly shown how nostalgia can
also be used to more positive ends in
kodak and the lens of nostalgia scholar
nancy martha west argues that nostalgia
does not necessarily entail retreat it
can equally function as retrieval as a
means of reclaiming the past and even of
shaping the future and we've seen that
with films like creed which hand the
rocky series off to a new generation of
characters in a way that both pays
tribute to the past and lays a new path
for the future sure we get that iconic
rocky music playing when adonis rises to
his feet in the climactic battle
[Music]
but we also get to see how the world has
begun to move beyond rocky himself the
film lets us be okay with the fact that
he's not the italian stallion anymore
and gives us a new hero to cheer for
similarly we've seen the star wars
sequels wrestle from picture to picture
with how much of the past they were
willing to kill in order to move the
series forward and how much time they
would rather spend simply playing the
hits one movie tries to move the story
on to a new set of characters who aren't
tied to the old heroes and villains then
the next one let the past die
kill it if you have to well the next one
you you know how it went somehow
palpatine returned but is there anything
redeeming about nostalgia that doesn't
explicitly move the series or franchise
forward maybe a 2012 oxford university
study called nostalgia the gift that
keeps on giving argued that nostalgia a
sentimental longing for a personally
experienced and valued past is a social
emotion it refers to significant others
in the context of momentous life events
and fosters a sense of social
connectedness and with something like
space jam when we are able to share a
nostalgic attachment and even maybe
transfer that nostalgic attachment from
one generation to another i.e from
millennial parents to their video game
obsessed kids we widen the web of people
whom we can connect with through it in a
modern era defined by discontinuity
maybe even something as goofy as space
jam a new legacy can offer us a little
of that much long-force sense of
stability because nostalgia isn't always
just about the past as fellaina boyam
argues the way we experience nostalgia
actually tells us more about the time we
are currently in than the one we're
looking back on and the future we're
looking towards she writes fantasies of
the past determined by the needs of the
present have a direct impact on the
realities of the future essentially you
can tell a lot about where we are right
now and where we are headed by which
parts of our past we choose to idealize
and which ones we try to re-evaluate or
discard and that in our estimation about
sums up space jam new legacy since 1935
i've been getting respect we're at a
point where the industry thinks that the
only reliable movie is the one you've
already seen leading to the sort of
cinematic snake eating its own tale
familiar characters charge through
scenes from familiar movies until the
end credits roll but what do you guys
think is the movie industry doomed to
become an ever-turning carousel of past
images for us to get misty-eyed over
or are there still exciting
possibilities to be explored in the era
of nostalgia let us know what you think
in the comments special shout out to our
patrons for all your support dunk on
that subscribe button like your king
james himself and don't forget to ring
that bell and as always thanks for
watching later
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you